Toy Story 4 is out and as of this taping
is at a jaw-dropping but unsurprising 98
percent certified fresh' putting it
right in line with its three
predecessors Toy Story at a hundred
percent Toy Story 2 also at a hundred
percent and Toy Story 3 at 98 percent
all certified fresh' do you know what
this means gang if Toy Story 4 is rating
holds that is going to make Toy Story
the most critically acclaimed franchise
in movie history isn't that insane is it
worth that praise we're gonna find out
hi everyone I'm Mark Ellis and welcome
back to the after show fair warning if
you haven't seen the movie this is
spoiler heavy so there you go
with that being said I have a fantastic
panel to get into Toy Story 4 with here
today with us we have 2 editors from
Rotten Tomatoes
Jaclyn Koli and Alex bow welcome back to
the show
thank you and then a round of applause
for them was done by the movie man the
movie manse himself mr. Scott movie
release dates man's dad is correct
I can go for the release dates of all
the Toy Story movies but I won't bore
you I know 95 and then 99 and then 2010
there you go well I definitely knew when
the fourth one came out because that's
2009 and this is a movie where there was
a lot of people wondering do we even
need to make this movie and so before we
get into all these kind of conversations
I just want to start with you Alex is
this a fresh or rotten film in your eyes
it's a fresh movie as a standalone movie
it works it's probably Pixar's funniest
movie as a continuation a series it's a
subpar Toy Story probably my least
favorite play story okay the what I
heard Scott is that it might be the
funniest movie Pixar's ever made so I
want to delve into that a little bit
later too fresh Arad for you big-time
fresh it's one of the funniest toy
stories movies ever made by Pixar I
liked it as a standalone film and I
liked it as the continuation of a series
a continuation that like you said we did
not need but we got it and it delivers
okay so we've got two freshes but kind
of differing opinions within those
Fresh's jacqueline so are you
contributing to that 98% as well make
things even more complicated
it was fresh for me as well I'm not the
person that runs to the cinema every
time there's like
Pixar Animation so there's a very low
bar for my freshness I will admit that
um it was good for movie aimed at
children
I was not bored it was good okay I
thought it was I'm not quite gonna go
love but I'm gonna say really really
really liked Toy Story 4 and I had the
good pleasure of being at d23 a few
years ago when they first announced the
Toy Story 4 was going to happen and it's
a big show and Randy Newman's out there
playing piano and you get swept up in
that then afterwards you start thinking
about wait we have may be the most
perfect trilogy in film history with the
first three toy stories so why do we
want to risk going back and having that
Golden Goose lay another egg so Alex was
it a worthwhile venture getting back
into this it sounds like you're a little
mixed on whether we need a date oyster
yeah on the same way I think like most
people when Toy Story 3 and I'm thinking
like that was the perfect ending I was
not a huge fan of Toy Story 3 the kind
of so I started for kind of doubled down
on things I didn't like about Toy Story
3 where I felt like the toys were really
starting to sort of shape the world a
lot there's just kind of like affecting
the plot a lot I came into it going
right well what's the point in
reinvesting into a story that I thought
was already done but the shift in the
movie it shifts from four key who I
think is a pretty lousy character it
confirmed my worst fear like no like
alright come back to the Toy Story movie
reinvest other okay what's the point
like here's a spork I'm like why I would
defend forky and eventually later on in
the show but just to bopi and i think
that is a story worth telling and you
know Toy Story 3 she gets cast aside
she's not going to movie this toy this
is a Toy Story 4 going this is Pixar
going it wasn't fair to make Bo Peep
just a sort of pain plot point for woody
she needs a story she needed a
resolution view the conclusion and that
is worth it ok well we we need a defense
for why this movie came out it's not
good enough just to say oh lo everybody
loves Toy Story
we've got Buzz and Woody so Jacqueline
what did this movie bring to the table
that you felt was were
of a return I mean honestly this is the
most brilliant thing ever absolutely Toy
Story 4 should happen because it did its
purpose which it set up a Toy Story
universe that they can now make into
television shows
maybe another movie they managed to
split up the dynamic duo of Buzz and
Woody in a way to where people are still
gonna be ok if you have The Adventures
of Buzz Lightyear or you have the
adventures of woody and Bo Peep it's
brilliant I think that it's really smart
I get maybe from a storytelling point
people are like why do we need it but
again low bar here on animation
brilliant there's gonna be like your
grandkids are gonna be talking about the
Toy Story movies because they have
literally given themselves a road map
for at least another 30 years yes god
it's shades and force awakens really
because it's like well we have these old
characters that we came to the theater
to see they're all split up and now we
have these new characters that we met so
they didn't with characters make the
return worthwhile okay I just took
capitalize on what Jaclyn was talking
about you know my bar was a lot higher I
mean I loved the Toy Story movies you
know all the other sequels that Pixar
has done like masters University and the
car sequels I finding Dory I don't like
those movies I didn't think that they
lived up to their predecessors but Toy
Story 4 definitely does see I loved Toy
Story 3 I thought that was the best of
the bunch and you're right mark that was
a perfect trilogy up there with The Lord
of the Rings trilogy and the recent
Planet of the Apes trilogy is one of the
greatest film trilogies of all time and
also the before trilogy before sunrise
before sunset before midnight brilliant
I I completely disagree with you about
four key I thought I knew every four key
was a wild wacky character and he four
key set the tone for Toy Story fourth to
be wild and wacky a little weird it gets
a little dark and introduces a whole
bunch of new characters Jacqueline like
you said that carries the series forward
keeps it fresh keeps it vibrant makes it
a toy story worth telling makes this
series worth continue I want to stay
with you for the darkness comment too
because I think that that leads to some
emotional moments and hearing people
walk out of the theater where I got to
see this movie a lot of them were saying
it
the most emotional of the bunch so what
moments really stood out to you when
when woody and forkie get to the antique
store at the roadside carnival so they
go into the the antique store and they
meet Gabby Gabby and her henchmen these
ventriloquist dummies which I had when I
was a kid which head of Danny O'Day when
I was a kid but ever since that that
Twilight Zone episode the dummy yeah you
know ventriloquist dummies have scared
the hell out of me and they do scare me
in this movie and Gabby Gabby's motive
her plan her sinister plan for what she
wants to do to woody you know spoiler
steal his voice box because hers is
broken that that got a little deep it
got a little dark it was unexpected but
at the same time I embraced it because I
felt like this is what's making the Toy
Story series grow up become a little
more mature become more for more for
growing up so I think than for kids I
think kids will be a little scared at
this point but I went with it and it was
another way that Toy Story 4 stood apart
from the first three movies yeah and
Jack when the Gabby Gabby stuff to me is
actually ironically would emotionally
grab me the most is when we actually
find out that well she does just want to
be loved she just wants to have her own
human companion so when she gets
rejected that hit me pretty hard and
then when she finds the lost girl and
she helps her out she knows this is her
mission in life did that affect you to
the point of Tears further confirmation
I don't know
no I didn't enjoy it though it
definitely did touch me it just didn't
drive me to the moment of seriously I
thought again like I appreciate Toy
Story 4 more for how smart it is then
for how much I actually enjoyed it I
thought it was really smart the way they
did Gabby because it pointed out
something that I think is kind of not
talked about the Toy Story what he had
it as far as like the like storied life
of a toy he had it he had a kid who
loved him he was the favorite toy for
many years the kid even gave him a
second life by giving him to someone
else in the world of toys were like love
is the commodity woody was rich and
privileged and had everything in front
of him so I think it's kind of
interesting
the way that Gabi put it to him it's
like look I just want a minute of what
you've had for your entire life now
granted her means of achieving it we're
a little bit you know sinister and
militant and those stupid ventriloquist
doll oh my god right but I think it was
very interesting and then this film has
a credit from rashida Jones and her
writing partner because they were
originally involved in the story and
then they left the story for for various
reasons involved in the production but I
think this is part of her fingerprints
when I look at the little book PEEP
stuff when I look at the Gabi Gabi stuff
I feel like her influence as a writer
she also wrote that black mirror episode
like you can just see where she has the
women I feel like what was written
through her I could feel it jumping out
and onto the page from the page and
certainly a lot of comedic moments in
there as well Alex you said that maybe
it's not your favorite Toy Story movie
but certainly may be the funniest Pixar
movie of all time what were some of the
funniest comedic scenes for you
yeah I think the inclusion of King Pele
playing oh they're great
yeah duck and buddy you can see it you
can see it was genius attacking those
two together being stitched together
like that be able to play upon their
sort of rapport from past no key key and
peele obviously do kaboom Keanu Reeves
all right steals a show and then you
know and then yo debian buddies sort of
their insane cutaway plans of how to get
back the key from the antique store
owner which are just fantastic yeah and
then at the very very end I think a lot
of people sort of forgot about this if
you stay into the very very end of the
credits there's a little bit of a
stinger there with do kaboom and the
action Carl's who doesn't get as high
five there's a great moment there and
what's great is uh all the action Carl's
are voiced by Carl Weathers and that's
my kind of joke
Keanu Reeves like what a moment he's
having right now between John Wayne III
being more six way more successful than
that the first two movies and his
inspire cameo in always be my Navy cyber
computer cyberpunk 2077 coming out next
year it's gonna be right and he gets to
be do kaboom in this and
I'll be honest with you I had no idea
Cantor Reeves was in the movie I did not
know so when do kaboom comes on I'm just
like this is a funny character and he's
making me laugh no idea I could not tell
it was counter ease until after I left
the theater and somebody told me that he
was actually doing a voice in there so
that's actually a great point to pick up
Scott is that when you look at this in
context of the new characters who was
the standout was it do kaboom was it for
key oh well you know I started off as
for key but then the you know the
interesting thing you know talking about
this the character that really like sort
of ran away with the movie for me it
started off with look think this could
be four keys thing you know we got to
make four can you feel good about
himself that he's a toy that he's one of
us that that Bonnie loves him obviously
she does but then the movie for the
first half of the film I thought it was
a little uneven that didn't really have
a focus it started to go off a go off a
little bit I'm like where is this going
but the second half of the movie it got
better as it went along especially when
you meet all these new characters like
duckie and bunny and just Keanu Reeves
just stole it like the whole like even
he is having an existential crisis
because of his owner that he can't make
the jump I mean it was that was
hilarious when he saw the head I mean it
was so funny back so you're not gonna
break Alex he's not even a forky fan I
mean but for ki I mean listen Tony Hale
who's a phenomenal and veep one of the
one of the great shows of the 21st
century is so so sympathetic and he's so
funny as for keys neurotic and he's like
totally anxious so you know it's I
thought it was too late it was four key
itself like you know look at all these
toys with the bells and whistles like
Buzz Lightyear and woody and then
there's fork and you're like what it was
I'm gonna wacky again how smart it is
they gave us a former LSD user toy with
an anxiety issue like that is what it is
like that's like like this dude did way
too many drugs in the 70s not quite
there he just wants to be in the trash
you know what I mean like it's all not
wired but completely like anxious and
neurotic and afraid of literally
everything you know the other thing the
other thing Jacqueline and Mark and Alex
is this just like that the second film
in the third film and now especially
this one like here's a Pixar movie
a Toy Story movie that is dealing with
pretty existential themes about purpose
and an embracing change and moving on
and let it go and you have these issues
especially with defining their purpose
with old cat with characters old and new
woody and forkie otro both trying to
figure out their purpose in a changing
world what he is still hanging on to
Andy even though he's been handed off to
Bonnie and now he's off on his own here
and like by the end of the film you
really see woody revitalized and um
these movies also because they came out
so far apart they came out at different
points in the lives of the movie goers
who watch them then past these movies on
maybe to their kids so with each passing
film movie goers are watching them at
different stages of their lives and
they're finding new ways to relate to
these movies if they can but Alex you
said you really didn't relate through
the character yeah all that much so I
wonder if I'm like the rest develop
right now you know obviously you know
one and two we're just you know
instrumental to my childhood I can't
believe it I'm like 40 40 there's my
probably four key is that look I have no
problem with like dumb characters or
stupid characters like Dumb and Dumber
is like I watched that movie every year
1994 yeah well like my problem is when a
character is so dumb or so not adapted
to the world that it affects the plot so
you have the Oh woody has classified in
this movie so much that he sort of has
this sort of sort of you take all his
nobility like I have to take care of 40
at the cost of all the other characters
of woody of a buzz of Jesse of bullseye
of everybody else so it's like it's like
playing it was like it felt like playing
like a PlayStation 2 game for my two
thousand where you're on an escort
mission what is on an escort mission
with this AI who is too stupid to live
all right no no I'm like just let go I
mean I did have that thought watching
the movie just thinking like look if the
worst happens the forky and he ends up
in a trash can that we can't find him is
this really gonna break this little
girls what is it you're capable but that
is the other reason why I get into
arguments with people about whether Toy
Story is aimed who it's aimed at for
keys aimed at an eight-year-old because
for an eight-year-old for ki is the man
for ki can do no
there is no toy there is no item greater
than 40 both the real-life version and
what they see on the screen it's gonna
be like the minions you're gonna see for
key everywhere lucky short exactly like
for key like with Tyco whitey he's gonna
show up at Comic Con next year in like a
four key so and I again I get why you
need that for kid you and you need the
fresh blood to like I would go to a
chain restaurant right now I need
pancakes with a four key character I
think I'd be a lot of fun for all of us
to do if Scott pays look at the
characters in this in this movie though
Alex I'd think you make a good point is
that if we have to jump away from these
older characters we need newer
characters to latch on to so do you
think that Woody and Buzz got the shaft
a little bit and some of these older
characters that didn't get a lot of
screen time I mean you have you know Rex
and mr. mrs. Potato Head I thought it
was great being able to bring back Don
Rickles his voice posthumously but do
you think that the old guard got a
little not as much screen time as you
would have liked yeah absolutely I think
you know coming into this movie I'm like
look all right I'll I'll take whatever
Pixar has has to offer and you're right
like you know these movies mean a lot to
people but I realize I was watching like
they mean they may need different things
to people in different ways like for a
lot of people Toy Story is about woody
it's about Woody's story I realized
while watching my stories about actually
Woody and Buzz and Jesse and so the fact
you know and like so when Woody is
hanging out with four key I was like
this is enough this is an opportunity
actually for us to get involved
the opportunity for Jesse to get
involved they spend the entire time in
RV you know buzz leaves for a little bit
but really he's sort of incidental and
he goes back I was really surprised that
how they sort of treated Buzz he's like
Drax yeah he has like blank stare
William both have been have been
together now for about what max for you
from the rector no tracks no moon
oh you're thinking too much yeah yeah
do you think that we didn't get enough
of particularly maybe buzz and some of
these other characters that we have come
to love from the first three movie okay
I agree and it was very noticeable that
that you know for usually when I think a
toy story I think of Woody and Buzz but
in this movie Buzz kind of took a
backseat to the rest of the story and
the development of some of the other
characters but III think I think Toy
Story is a whole lot more than just
about Woody and Buzz or just about buddy
these Toy Story movies are about the
inevitability of change of embracing the
change of letting go and evolving and
moving forward and that was definitely
the case with the second film the third
film and that and especially this fourth
movie I know that's that's way too
grown-up but that's why I'm Jacqueline I
with you I think these movies as they
grow and evolve they're a little more
for grown-ups
every time well something that I know is
going to be lighting up the comment
section is who is your favorite new
character and before we say goodbye to
this particular segment Jack when I want
the final gabble to go to you your
favorite new character and an older
character that you would have liked to
have seen more of doesn't like run to
animation to try to remember the name
I'll give you I'll give you duckie and
bunny Gabby no I got it the new
characters I can remember because it's
duckie and bunny without question Jordan
Peele at Key & Peele is honestly the
best thing that ever happened to Toy
Story in my opinion it was the best
thing buzz did in this movie which
introduced us - yeah - duckie and bunny
and that zip tie everything that that
introduced them to the world because I
do think they can pop up again I was
really lamented that they did not get
both of them to do The Lion King to do
Timon and Pumbaa like no offense to
Billy Eichner and Seth Rogen but that to
me was like the perfect pairing but
we'll see what happens they were the
best ones old character I'd like to see
more of the dog maybe down with that one
huh look let's talk about this though
for the first time at a Toy Story movie
the commodity was not love from a child
I thought that
really interesting cuz normally it's
like we got to get Andy to love me or
Andy loves buzz more than he loves me or
Jesse you know she didn't love me at all
this one woody at the end of it stands
true and himself to be like no I'm gonna
have a life and a love and an existence
outside of a kid it was really
interesting cuz they you're right it's
about change but more importantly when
the change is not what you expected it
to be when your life literally turns out
completely different than expected yeah
so I mean I think we're all taking a cue
from bo-peep here where it's like we're
toys are gonna get more independent and
maybe see if we have more adventures
before we get to that question I want to
bring up our next segment which is how
great is Toy Story historically I mean
we mentioned that the tomato meter
scores are off the charts the there's
only one franchise as a matter of fact
that competes with Toy Story for the
best ranked movies according to the
tomato meter to you Jacqueline do you
know what is it okay I just god knows
what it is Alex
Jacqueline anybody out there you want to
guess it is the before drill yeah so I
have this goat before sunrise is a
hundred percent before sunset is 95
percent and before midnight is 97
percent so that's really good do you
think the Toy Story with this new
incarnation Scott is gonna leap past the
before franchise possibly greatest I
think it'll be equal because after
before sunset came out in nineteen and
2004 no one knew that it before midnight
was going to happen nine years later and
after Toy Story 3 came out in 2010
everyone fully expected that to be it
because I've wrapped it up really good
and here we are nine years later with
Toy Story 4 so having said that do I
think that a Toy Story 5 is plausible
impossible yes do I think that'll happen
maybe 9 or 10 years down the line
absolutely do I think we're going to get
another before movie nine years after
before midnight yes and the reason why
both of these series work so well is
because of the tremendous amount of time
in between films people are at different
stages of their lives when a new
installment comes out and they relate to
these movies in different ways that's
what I loved about about this about Toy
Story 4 about just like you said Jack
what about the run
all doubt from under you and after
having to adapt to change life doesn't
turn out the way you wanted to but you
got to go with it and that's what I
loved about this movie I might not have
felt that way 10 years ago but I do
today and if you look at the lineage of
Toy Story first coming on 95 and then
this one 2019
Jaqueline do you think it's worthy of
the title most critically acclaimed
franchise in history I mean look I think
it is definitely probably yes but I want
to again make it a distinction that I
look at something like the before series
as more I would say still so than
something like Toy Story like you got
kids to enjoy an animated movie and when
the critics are judging it they're
judging it for that they're not judging
it for some edgy avant-garde take a huge
risk and have it pay off you see what
I'm saying like you look like a film I
get out where literally Jordan Peele
went completely in a different direction
for horror and revitalized reach Ange
dit like really putting a stamp on the
genre and it's like what ended up at
like 98 percent fresh on the tomato
meter that to me is a huge achievement
getting kids to enjoy a kids movie and
make it an enjoyable kids movie you know
what I mean like I feel like there's a
different bar an interesting point you
already have a leg up when you're trying
to entertain kids primarily if you have
cute and cuddly things that are easily
they're easily merchandised
you know I don't know there's a lot of
before sunset before sunrise before Sun
right pogs I don't think or at least not
me when I'm when I was doing it as a
critic I wouldn't sit down and judge get
out the same way I'm gonna judge Toy
Story like they're just two separate
movies and the judging Alex how does
that hit your ear if I say the Toy Story
is the most critically acclaimed
franchise in movie history yeah I think
it makes us because like again the way
the themes change on what stage of life
you're in and how it hits you that's
important but taking like but taking
like before series I don't think it's
gonna go beyond the trilogy because you
know the first movie opens with that
bickering couple and then at the end of
before midnight or at before midnight
they're sort of that couple you know so
I had that sort of there was a running
out of times in the day yeah
they are before 4:30 like what's the
next Tory story it made it very easy mr.
four five six seven eight nine but if
you are the before franchise or your
even like something that's a little bit
more pop corny like a like an MCU or a
DC sorry comic book fans I know you more
than popcorn movies Star Wars Star Trek
I'll throw in there The Hobbit movies
Lord of the Rings middle-earth what can
all these other franchises Scott learn
from what Toy Story has done character
it's all about the characters it's all
about the story but it's all about the
characters characters that you love and
that you grow to love more over the
years because the characters change and
grow and evolve at at the same time that
you also change and grow and evolve and
that's the thing they the Toy Story
films the before movies they never
repeated themselves they took chances
this one Toy Story 4 it took chances as
well it was a little darker it was a
little it got a little weird and I mean
that I say that in a good way because it
made this movie stand on its own but yet
still felt like the continuation of a
series where all the movies were great
but it's all because you know we like
the new characters and it makes it fresh
and vibrant but we love the old
characters too we want to see where they
are their life while we're looking at
where we are in ours yeah Alex and few
are a sports teams I'm allowed one
sports metaphor for show if you get into
the game film room and you're watching
Toy Story and you're any one of these
other big franchises what's the take
away what are you trying to incorporate
from Toy Story into your movies yeah I
would agree character thinking about
where you could take the character from
one place to another from one movie to
another thinking about how much I mean
how much weight can a series taking with
all these new characters and then it's
also staying true to what to what
audiences believe in but again I feel
like Toy Story kind of pushed me for
kind of view it off a little bit off of
that yeah so do you agree with a
character sentiment that's what these
other franchises can kind of take the
ball and run with it is that you have to
not only give us characters we care
about but also give them at different
stages in their lives or careers and we
glom on to everything that they're doing
I'll let me get a stipulation I think
that you can learn from them as far as
the long-running franchise and I think
the thing because I don't think every
movie can learn from them on this but
again if you're thinking about doing
sequels this idea that you can kill your
darlings later on in the franchise so
this idea that like and something maybe
by accident or on purpose Little Bo Peep
wasn't involved in Toy Story 3 so they
kind of killed that darling they didn't
try to wedge her in there in places that
she didn't fit which then gave them this
opportunity to write this entire film on
Toy Story 4 so they had to be able to do
that and then in this film killing your
darlings would be breaking up Buzz and
Woody like that had to be a conversation
with people and so I think that's the
lesson you should learn is that don't
get so wrapped up in the rules that you
created for these characters and don't
be afraid and breaking them if the story
tells you to all right I don't know if
we're ever getting another before movie
but I will put a lot of money on the
fact that we are gonna get a Toy Story 5
at some point down the road I think
we're all in agreement that we're
getting a new Toy Story movie somewhere
I don't even think it's gonna take 9
years like you do Scott I think we could
get a new Toy Story 5 announced sooner
rather than later stay off I am more
keeping an eye out on that Toy Story on
Disney Plus cuz I feel like that is
gonna be the next thing that we probably
yeah they're already doing shorts or
done shorts in between three and four so
I did agree like Toy Story 4 feels like
a Toy Story universe movie as opposed
for me a Toy Story I'm at 40 short I
want a 4k you're gonna get a 4k
apparently on Disney plus it's four key
answers questions so a lot more Alex I
guess you're gonna have to avoid that
therefore the mandalorian but yeah I
think that you can take a note from what
Star Wars is is looking with what
they're doing with Disney Plus is that
we're gonna use Disney Plus the launch
shows that are gonna keep the galaxy
alive and then we're gonna have our
standalone movies come out or maybe
maybe another saga movie down the road
it could be the same thing with Toy
Story where we get a lot of individual
characters that have their short-run
shows and then we come back to Toy Story
five years down the line here is what
happens in Toy Story 5 just like Andy
passed off the toys to bonnie bonnie is
gonna pass the toys off to andy's kid
mmm cuz and II went to college in three
right so now and II like it's gonna take
place a few years down the line yeah and
you know it's a good time for Bonnie bye
it's gonna grow up she's gonna pass on
the toys to the next person and it just
it's just by by happenstance it's gonna
be Andy's kids full circle the circle of
life all right that's a very good pitch
for Toy Story 5 we just got so Alex and
Jack and I want to close up shop here by
getting the individual standalone
character you'd most like to see on
Disney Plus and I know your answer is
not 40 you know I would love to see more
of for buzz your buzz had that cartoon
in like the late 90s which was like not
that great but more I don't know more
space adventures more of more buzz like
what not a buzz is simply sharing kohli
duties with Jesse kind of seeing where
he may be reestablishing his character
back and about to like you know part to
levels and then kind of seeing where we
go from there
all right that gets embed get some
eyeballs on it Jacqueline how about your
character for Disney Plus in the toy
store use my character I have the show I
would like a variety series with ducky
and Buddy where they have musical
interlude breaks like the old gym music
videos it'd be one and a half minute
breaks and they would come in it would
literally be Park Carson Park Muppet
Babies Park Jim the animated serial
ducky and bunny doesn't he make it
happen
I don't know who gave you the key to my
heart but I would like it back that is
an incredible show that's gonna get
adults watching that do you have a great
pitch for the new movie Alex you had it
you did a great job with Disney plucks
Jacqueline's pitch is the one that I'm
buying none of them are coming to pass
just yet but you do have a four key
franchise to look forward to on Disney
Plus and somewhere down the line is
gonna be Toy Story 5 well I want to
thank you all for joining us on this
episode of the after show thanks to our
lovely panel and thanks to all of you
for checking it out along with us make
sure you comment right now let us know
your thoughts on Toy Story 4 who is your
favorite new character which old
character did you want to see more of
what is your pitch for a new Toy Story
movie a new Disney flush of featuring
Toy Story we want to hear all of it
right now make sure you subscribe to
this channel and hit that Bell it's
going to give you a nice little alert
next time an after show is coming your
way until then I'm
gelus and there's a snake in my boot
[Music]